Okay.
Let's talk a little bit about geopolitics
and alliances.
All right?
We live in a world of countries.
That's how the the planet is organized.
For the most part.
We can disagree with the concept of nation
states.
There are anarchists who do.
There are others who do a, we could argue
that nation states have been a negative influence
on human wellbeing, but we get that.
That's a debate that we could have a right
now, nation states exist and they are one
of the most influential types of administrative
body that affects the lives of the nearly
8 billion people on Earth.
So the point is relationships between nation
states are of huge importance, period.
Some of the largest damage that Donald Trump
has done, some of the most difficult to undo
damage that Donald Trump has done is to our
relationships with our historical allies,
alienating us from many of our historical,
western democratic allies and instead sucking
up in Brown nosing more and more to the authoritarians
and the brutal dictators.
And this ranges from, you know, going from
memory.
You've got Kim Jong UN and North Korea Turkeys
Airto on.
Yeah, you're both scenario in Brazil.
Vladimir Putin in Russia, of course, President
Xi in China, Rodrigo Duterte in the Philippines.
There might be others that that I'm forgetting.
A British Prime Minister Theresa May has now
straight up condemned Donald Trump.
As I've already covered.
Donald Trump made these xenophobic tweets
over the weekend, directed at freshman members
of Congress such as Alexandria, Casteo, Cortez
and others suggesting they go back to their
countries, their countries.
Of course being the United States.
Typical red meat right wing xenophobia meant
to distract from the endless Trump scandals
that are going on.
I already talked about that, the widespread
condemnation from the American left, but now
Theresa May is jumping into the fray, is certainly
no bleeding heart liberal to say the least.
Then in a statement, her official spokesman
said, quote, the prime minister's view is
that the language used to refer to these women
was completely unacceptable.
Period.
Full Stop.
Okay.
This is not language that the leaders of our
major allies tend to use about the president
of the United States, and this is again, forging
new ground in this rapid decline that Donald
Trump has been able to catalyze in our relationships
with our historical allies.
And once again, I know that the Trump is right
and much of the broader American right doesn't
give to, you know what's about this.
Some Europeans don't like Trump.
Good.
Screw him because Trump is doing stuff that's
good for us, not what's good for them, and
I support Trump, make America great again.
I'm going to order 10 more of those stupid
red hats.
Now, there is a fair criticism to make here,
which is that very easy and convenient for
Theresa May to say this.
Now she's on her way out.
It's very easy for her now to say this, since
it doesn't matter what the political consequences
are of directly condemning the statements
of an American president.
She's going to be gone soon, and that's true,
but that actually should be a warning to us.
Okay?
There are likely many more leaders of our
allies that are thinking the same things as
Theresa May better seeing what Donald Trump
says and does, and their sincerely held belief
is one of wanting to condemn it, but they're
not doing it because they've got to work with
Trump for at least a couple more years.
Because the truth is that this isn't even
close to the first unacceptable thing that
Donald Trump has done or said.
So the idea that only now does Theresa May
find Donald Trump's actions can demel.
That's laughable.
She's preparing to no longer be the prime
minister of Britain.
It's a red flag that we're only now hearing
this from her for the first time.
And what it says to me is that more than likely
there are many world leaders who are just
biting their tongues because they would have
to deal with the political repercussions of
saying, this guy is disgusting.
We condemn what Donald Trump has said.
We condemn what Donald Trump has done.
So I hope that more and more world leaders
will say what's on their minds.
It needs to be made clear that only American
Trumpists see this as normal.
Okay?
The American left.
Most American moderates obviously don't see
what's going on as normal, but it's important
and it would be useful to make clear that
most of the world sees what's going on is
outrageous.
This is not what the office of the American
presidency should be or should stand for.
So no real pat on the back for a Theresa May
for me.
Certainly none for all of the other world
leaders who are keeping quiet, let's hear
them say what they really think and then let's
have to deal with the repercussions.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
Follow me there.
Follow me on Twitter.
Uh, you can also follow the David Pakman show
on Twitter at the David Pakman show for all
the latest news and content from the show.
Daylen the David Pakman show